[Music]
tense times for a BC town this Monday
night the fear is a frightening Wildfire
could flare up when it is a wind-driven
fire we do see that significant growth
what's in the forecast
the lingering pain of the pandemic
there's some Dark Nights the struggle
for small businesses as a deadline to
pay back Federal loans creeps closer
strike action why economists predict
more people will walk off their jobs
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with the threat from
wildfires and the hundreds of people out
of their homes in BC this fire near the
town of osuyu is a popular summer
destination for tourists near the U.S
border doesn't look threatening right
now but fire crews are keeping a close
eye on it knowing it can flare up in an
instant
it's a foreign tornado
it blew up on the weekend winds whipping
those Flames straight towards town
turning the sky orange and prompting
evacuation orders a local state of
emergency remains in effect
the Wildfire is almost doubled in size
since Crossing into Canada it's now more
than 1400 hectares and conditions in
that part of BC are so hot and dry fire
officials are taking nothing for granted
Heather urac's West is in the region
tonight Heather
Donna after a clear morning here in Asus
it has become very smoky in this
community as the Eagle Bluff Wildfire
burns into its third evening the
situation however is stabilizing enough
that hundreds of residents are being
allowed to return home after a tense and
terrifying few days
oh boy Rocky it was sunshine and Blue
Skies over osuyas Lake Monday but things
are far from normal in this holiday town
a sunny July day on the beach here is
usually jammed with tourists the Water
full of boats we were sitting at the
another restaurant and everybody around
us everybody on every table was on their
phone booking something else for you
know for that night look at that it was
this terrifying scene Saturday night
that sent everyone away Flames covering
the Mountainside as the Eagle Bluff
Wildfire jumped the Canada U.S border
coming dangerously close to the BC Town
it was really a strong wind you could
see the ambers jumping and like creating
fires in front of the big fire yeah we
watched it the whole night pushing up on
the mountain there and at some point the
wind changed and it started pushing the
fire back onto Itself by Sunday the
Flames flared a second time Crews
responded battling from the ground and
the sky dumping water and fire retardant
on trees below but it's the weather and
specifically the wind that's been the
key driver of this town's fate when it
is a wind-driven fire we do see that
significant growth is that brushes
forward and dries out the fuels that are
in front of it as well and then that
helps them more easily ignite
foreign
it meant Flames inching closer to
businesses in the darkness Sunday had
retreated by dawn after the winds
shifted overnight are you feeling like
you're out of the woods now like oh yes
yes no qualms whatsoever still this
remains a very Dynamic situation and
while an evacuation order has been
lifted for hundreds of residents an
evacuation alert remains in effect the
fire threat may have diminished but
there are many hot dry days ahead Donna
all right Heather urich's West thanks
well fighting wildfires is dangerous
work tonight there's more information
about the young firefighter from Ontario
who has killed battling BC's largest
blaze in history Zachary Freeman Muse
was 25 years old he died when the
utility terrain vehicle he was riding
rolled over a steep drop on a gravel
road Muse was working as a contract
firefighter north of Fort St John BC
battling the Donny Creek Wildfire he is
the second firefighter killed in BC the
fourth to die in Canada this season
in Nova Scotia the search for a youth
still missing after being Swept Away in
catastrophic flooding over a week ago
has been temporarily suspended RCMP say
Searchers have encountered Deep Pockets
of water that are too dangerous to
explore
these pockets of water have low
visibility and unpredictable Terrain
as a result a search of the ponds by The
Searchers would put them in risk of
being injured
police do say those pockets of water are
draining quickly on their own four
people went missing on July 22nd when
their vehicles became submerged in flood
waters the bodies of two children and a
52 year old man have been recovered
the Canada industrial Relations Board is
warning the union representing BC port
workers against changing its mind about
ratifying another new tentative deal
with employers the board says it would
be unfair Labor practice both sides
reached a new negotiated agreement last
night that could finally bring an end to
the month-long dispute that has
paralyzed ports across western Canada
Mackenzie gray reports
after nearly a month of negotiations
it's hoped the third time is the charm
to end a costly labor dispute a late
night statement from the international
Longshore workers union says they've
secured a negotiated tentative
settlement with the BC Maritime
employers Association we now have a
situation where there is another offer
there is another potential deal on the
table neither side offered a glimpse of
the new deal but previous tentative
agreements haven't stuck Union
leadership rejected the first pact on
July 13th and on Saturday the membership
voted down a second agreement that
included a 19.2 percent compounded wage
increase over four years a three
thousand dollar signing bonus and a lump
sum retirement payment the employer said
that would boost the median annual wage
for Longshore workers to 162 thousand
dollars excluding pension and benefits
but the union still had issues around
contract workers and automation when
you're faced with that kind of uncertain
future it's no wonder that you a worker
would demand better working conditions
in terms of automation or AI
the 7400 Port workers have been on the
job for the past two weeks but
uncertainty around the labor dispute LED
shipping companies and businesses to
avoid sending Goods through BC ports
that impact combined with a 13-day
closure from the strike cost the
Canadian economy billions and created a
massive backlog of goods it'll take
roughly seven days for every day of
strike before this is settled the
economic impacts putting pressure on the
federal government to find a resolution
leading labor Minister Sheamus O'Regan
to call in the Canada industrial
Relations Board who helped mediate the
most recent tentative agreement our
serious responsible government is going
to continue to do the work necessary the
Longshore workers will vote on ratifying
the tentative deal this Friday and if it
doesn't pass expect the federal
government to impose binding arbitration
on both parties Donna to ensure the BC
ports stay open
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
it has been a summer of strikes a little
later we'll explore the common thread
and the frustration of those on strike
and why some economists warn there is
more to come the deadline is looming for
hundreds of thousands of Canadian
business owners who took out Federal
loans during the pandemic repayments
under the Canada emergency business
account or siba are due at the end of
December and a growing number of
businesses are pleading for an extension
saying they still haven't bounced back
turia isri reports
for restaurants still recovering from
covid-19 it can be hard to look at the
glass half full
Ivan gedz owns a bar in downtown Ottawa
and has not paid himself in five months
I'm probably going to try and push
through till the spring
but the amount that I'm leveraging my
personal home in order to do that and so
on and so forth is
there's some dark nights he's one of
almost a million Canadian business
owners who took out a Federal Loan to
survive lockdowns and avoid shutting
down permanently during the pandemic and
the due date is coming up
Ottawa offered a loan of up to sixty
thousand dollars and there was a major
perk up to twenty thousand dollars would
be forgiven and no interest charged if
the loan was repaid by December 31st
2023 but forgets that's not an option
right now there's no way even though we
would love to take advantage of that
forgiveness the Canadian Federation of
Independent Business is pushing the
government for an extension the cfib
warns one-fifth of Canadian businesses
will be at risk of closing their doors
unless the deadline is extended we're
not saying forgive the debt we're not
going that far we're telling them just
give business owners small business
owners more time many business owners
did not anticipate stubborn inflation
Rising interest rates higher food and
fuel costs and the fact office workers
never fully returned downtown but some
economists insist the money has to come
from somewhere and that taxpayers can't
subsidize struggling businesses the
federal government says it's already
extended the deadline by a year in terms
of a plan for paying back there is
currently none gym owner Mark longellier
opened in the pandemic and needs some
wiggle room it would push push us into
the red for sure
so now
uh you know I think we would still give
it a shot for next uh six to 12 months
without an extension lingerie fears his
business and many others will disappear
along with the jobs that come with them
Taria is rate Global News Ottawa
in the U.S the property manager of
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago estate made
his first court appearance today Carlos
to oliviera is accused of scheming with
the former president to delete security
footage connected to the investigation
into alleged mishandling of classified
documents found at Trump's resort to
oliviera didn't enter a formal plea his
arraignment has been pushed August 10th
Trump and his aide Walt nalta have
pleaded not guilty to charges of
conspiracy to obstruct Justice and lying
to investigators and Trump could be
facing another grand jury indictment in
the coming weeks a Georgia judge has
rejected the former president's attempt
to derail his potential prosecution for
trying to subvert the 2020 election
results a state prosecutor began an
investigation after the release of a
recording of a phone call Trump made to
George's secretary of state that phone
call during which he asked him to find
11 780 votes enough to have him win the
state
an ultimatum issued in Niger coming up
what could happen if that country's
president is not reinstated
[Music]
funerals are being held for the victims
of a suicide bombing in Pakistan on
Sunday the death toll has reached 54
nearly 200 others are injured supporters
of a pro-taliban political party were
demonstrating in Pakistan's Northwest
near the border with Afghanistan when
the blast happened the so-called Islamic
state is claiming responsibility
and the clock is ticking on an ultimatum
for the military Junta that orchestrated
a coup in Niger West African nations
have given military leaders there one
week to reinstate the country's
democratically elected president
threatening Force if their demands are
not met strict sanctions are also being
imposed which could have an impact on
one of the world's poorest countries
Crystal commencing Reports
a message on state television those were
responsible for the military coup warned
Niger could be attacked in an effort to
reinstate the president La France the
Army spokesperson accuses France of
plotting to strike with the help of
those inside the toppled government
the claim further stoked internal
frustrations on Sunday some residents
burned the French flag vandalized the
embassy in Miami and chanted anti-french
slogans
Niger was a French Colony until 1960.
the economic community of West African
states did Issue a notice to coup
leaders Sunday saying it has zero
tolerance for unconstitutional change
and that if the government was not
restored within one week it would take
all measures necessary
the German defense minister is the
latest Western leader to say the
situation is being closely monitored
like many Western Nations including
Canada it has soldiers in the region
associated with training missions
Germany followed the EU France the UK
and the 15 Nation West African Bloc
freezing economic aid to Niger
and journalist Alberto says tough
sanctions imposed on his country could
be a means of deterring future coups in
the region
I think we are really going to suffer
economically is going to be a very
difficult time for the country
the president of Chad Idris Debbie met
with military leaders Sunday and
appeared in and shared the first photo
of niger's elected president Muhammad
bazoom since he was taken captive July
26th the International Community
condemns the unconstitutional change of
government and has been demanding the
release of Bazoo
Crystal commencing Global News London
in southern Ukraine Russian missile
strikes have hit President Vladimir
zielinski's hometown
Russia's attack destroyed two
residential buildings and a university
and administrative building the strikes
killed at least four people including a
ten-year-old girl her mother and buried
others under the rubble at least 43
people have been injured
in China a typhoon has killed at least
two people in Beijing and has dropped
Relentless rain on the Chinese capital
foreign
cars were swept away after falling into
a river when the bridge they were on
broke in half another video shows a man
clinging to a vehicle as it floats in
flood waters before he was rescued by
firefighters it is beijing's worst
flooding in a decade turning hundreds of
Roads into rivers forcing tens of
thousands of people from their homes
summer of strikes ahead what's to blame
for a wave of Labor disputes
labor unrest seems to be touching many
lives this summer from BC port workers
to Toronto grocery store employees to
writers and actors in the entertainment
industry strikes are becoming a summer
staple and gaviola looks at the common
themes driving employees to strike and
why economists say to brace for more
combine a tight labor market the highest
interest rates in a generation and an
affordability crisis while the rich keep
getting richer just give us a little bit
more a piece of the pie we help them to
make this money so we deserve better the
summer of strikes is here and economists
say we should expect even more labor
unrest whether it's BC port workers
screenwriters and actors or Toronto area
Metro grocery workers there's a Common
Thread to the frustration jobs being
eroded too much part-time work not
enough high quality jobs with benefits
and and all of the things that we need
in our lives to be able to support our
families and you can only do that for so
long before people push back and our
members are right now pushing back and
pushing back hard more than 3 000
uniform members are striking at 27 Metro
locations unifor is the largest private
sector Union in Canada and also
represents some Global News employee
ease I've heard a lot of my co-workers
talking about using food banks and and
my myself like I said I've been 25 years
with the company I live in gear to
income housing because I can't afford
Market rent anywhere else in the city in
a statement Monday to Global News Metro
said it provided significant increases
for employees in addition to improved
pension benefits and working conditions
that are among the highest in the
industry Tiff Macklin last summer warned
Canadian workers to moderate their wage
demands and he said that if you get a
little too out of hand you're going to
be a source of inflation that we're not
currently factoring into our forecasts
that's still true today in the case of
the grocery workers they saw a temporary
bump in compensation during the pandemic
Canada's three largest grocery companies
Loblaw Empire and Metro reported more
than a hundred billion dollars in sales
combined and 3.6 billion in profit last
year what is eventually agreed upon here
sets a precedent for future negotiations
in the industry a new PWC poll shows 42
percent of Canadian employees say they
have nothing left over for savings after
paying their bills and nearly one in
four workers say they're looking for a
new job in the next year another Factor
anxiety about how AI will impact their
industry and job prospects all of this
points to the potential for strikes this
fall as well Donna all right I'm gaviola
in Toronto tonight thanks what's next
for Canada's national women's soccer
team after their big loss at the World
Cup
[Music]
then you're crazy I know you are but
what am I you're a nerd I know you are
but what am I
it was the irrepressible childlike Joy
of his character Pee-wee Herman that
made Paul Reubens famous Rubens has died
at the age of 70. and a social media
post his team said Rubens died from the
cancer he'd been diagnosed with six
years ago something he'd kept private
with his red bow tie and signature gray
suit Rubens launched the Whimsical
Pee-wee Herman show in 1980 first on
stage where it became a cult favorite
and then on TV a statement he wrote
posted on Instagram after his death says
I have always felt a huge amount of love
and respect from my friends fans and
supporters I have loved you all so much
and enjoyed making art for you
well Canada's run at the Women's World
Cup has come to a disappointing end the
team couldn't overcome the PowerHouse
Australian team or hosting the Women's
Soccer Championship this year Eric
Sorensen reports on the loss and where
it leaves Canada's women's team
as always Christine Sinclair was front
and center for Canada's biggest match
but when play began the Australians
quickly took control and with the fans
of the World Cup's host nation behind
them the Matilda's never let up a
telling moment for the Canadian team and
Canadian soccer came when the second
half began the greatest player of all
time was no longer on the pitch The
40-Year-Old Sinclair put on the
sidelines where she would watch the
team's World Cup come to an early end I
think
I was with them right till 11
's and it just wasn't our night tonight
if not the end of an era it signals a
transition from the first great
generation of women's soccer in this
country defined and led by Christine
Sinclair from her individual records 190
International goals all-time leader
among women and men's soccer to the
Canadian team records two bronze and a
gold medal in successive Olympics
as the face of the Canadian women's game
and a marketing brand for the sport
Sinclair has also LED women's soccer off
the field in its quest for equality as
she once told Global Nationals Donna
Friesen Sinclair has always been clear
about her goals for the women's game
every chance that a guy gets I want a
girl to get we're moving in the right
direction but like at a very slow pace
she's been a remarkable servant to the
national team John Molinaro says
Canadian soccer must now evolve as other
countries have caught up to the Canadian
women this team has sort of relied far
too much on Christine Sinclair for years
now but cannot simply rely on what
worked on the past you said could this
be Christine Sinclair's last game breaks
my heart the next generation of Canadian
players like Olivia Smith represent a
promising future in September Canada has
a qualifying match for next year's
Olympics it's not clear what roles
Sinclair might play but she acknowledged
the change is coming saying this was
probably her last World Cup Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is Hell hill pond near Cape Royal
Newfoundland and Labrador don't let the
name fool you it is a beautiful spot
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you